one of the great impediments to
understanding bits of our lives properly
is our overly ready assumption that we
already do so it's easy to carry around
with us and exchange with others
surface intellectual descriptions of key
painful events that leave the marrow of
our emotions behind
we may say that we remember for example
that we didn't get on too well with our
father that our mother was slightly
neglectful or that going to boarding
school was a bit sad
it could on this basis sound as if we
surely have a solid enough grip on
events but these compressed stories are
precisely the sort of ready-made
effectless accounts that stand in the
way of connecting properly and
viscerally with what happened to us and
therefore of knowing ourselves
adequately
if we can put it in a paradoxical form
our memories are what allow us to forget
our day-to-day accounts may bear as much
resemblance to the vivid truth of our
lives as a postcard from naxxos does to
a month-long journey around the aegean
if this matters it's because only on the
basis of proper immersion in past fears
sadnesses rages and losses can we ever
recover from certain disorders that
develop when difficult events have grown
immobilized within us
to be liberated from the past we need to
mourn it and for this to occur we need
to get in touch with what it actually
felt like we need to sense in a way we
may not have done for decades the pain
of our sister being preferred to us or
of the devastation of being maltreated
in the study on a saturday morning
the difference between felt and lifeless
memories could be compared to the
difference between a mediocre and a
great painting of spring both will show
us an identifiable place and time of
year but only the great painter will
properly seize from among millions of
possible elements the few that really
render the moment charming interesting
sad or tender in one case we know about
spring in the other we finally feel it
this may seem like a narrow aesthetic
consideration but it goes to the core of
what we need to do to get over many
psychological complaints we cannot
continue to fly high over the past in
our jet plane while high-handedly
refusing to re-experience the territory
we are crossing
we need to land our craft get out and
walk inch by painful inch
through the swampy reality of the past
we need to lie down perhaps on a couch
maybe with music
close our eyes and endure things on foot
only when we have returned afresh to our
suffering and known it in our bones
will it ever promise to leave us alone
please do comment like and subscribe and
take a look at our shop for more from
the school of life
you